chris hemsworth the avenger is signed on
with the men in black and only we can
take you behind
I'm certainly a fan myself
it wasn't excitement about what this
next chapter could be Chris's new
chapter hits the box office seven years
after MIB three in total Will Smith's og
trilogy made more than 1.6 billion
dollars men and black international
takes place in the same universe as
previous families let's do this when you
put the glasses on you have a whole suit
and all comes together we looked at each
other and fertilizes this is pretty cool
joining Chris's age of 8 to hunt for a
mole in the agency is Tessa Thompson as
agent in she definitely has her
reservations about him the first time
she sees him is very very funny
his approach to things definitely
bothers her I feel extreme you know and
then we just can't seem to get rid of
each other well it's not gonna save
itself
I'm driving that really should be here
this country Tessa was in thor ragnarok
and Avengers in game and jumped at the
chance to work with Chris again you know
he's so gifted at comedy he's so fun to
play with he doesn't miss a B in terms
of improving yeah he's a dream he's just
a dream to work with the men and women
in black
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]